I started to grow over Christmas I was
saying I'm gonna grow a beard everyone's
got a beard right Drew's got a beard
Jeremy's got a beard Matt's got a beer
I'll grow a beard so I start growing
that's you know it's whatever I'm
looking a little scraggly but it's and
it's a little bit on the a little on the
patchy sort of but I can grow a mustache
in about four hours that is the why it
takes me 10 years to grow beard I can
grow a mustache in a blink of an eye but
some guys are not meant for mustaches
and I give a lot of talks at schools and
if I grow out this mustache I I will not
be permitted within 300 yards of the
school I just reject that I think that
you should do it I'm very Pro mustache
okay I think it's a great look and
mustaches are back as far as I know all
right I mean I love them I love a good
mustache yeah and you could probably get
the whole because you got to go the
whole oh yeah I can get it mine's like a
slug mine is like a disgusting slug On
My Level that's what it's called crumb
catcher that's what it needs to be yeah
little soup strainer is what it is